è la tutti ragazzi e benvenuti a questo
nuovo video sono fatti j
oggi stiamo su bale di wei di will be
wilder saul ragazzi un videogame indie
horror che mi avete consigliato in
tantissimi ultimamente ho deciso di
farlo perché dagli screenshot sembrava
diciamo diversissimo da tutti quelli che
ho fatto finora e la cosa stranissima e
che cioè è ambientato in un parco giochi
cioè non ho capito un cazzo dicono che
ho visto ma va bene di nizza ragazzi
prima di tentare conclusioni che non ho
ancora capito cosa ha perso la mamma io
sono un po vj sono fabio sono una buona
mamma rai aspettate un secondo che cazzo
succede
diamo ruotando lo schermo perfetto ok ok
scusate ti devi svegliare senza sapere
come cazzo ci sia arrivato qui perché
sennò non va bene quindi ci stiamo cioè
l'unico [ __ ] gioco dove ci si muove
coi tasti direzionali invece che con
questi sei imposti da ottenere la
tastiera così perfetto giochiamo
comodissimo tra l'altro ragazzi qua per
passare c'è scritto che bisogna essere
almeno alti così qualcuno io sono quello
all'altezza del mio cane
carla bruni dove cazzo siamo ragazzi non
lo so ci siamo svegliati in un posto
bellissimo tra l'altro dovresti prendere
la mappa no ma io c'ho tomtom ma
guardiamo avanti la cama le mappe chi lo
sa più cos'è questo è un bimbo io non
l'ho mai visto una mappa fatta migliore
questo è il nuovo tomtom attenzione mai
visto meglio di così ai future rom
market to your map devo andare nella
stanza che marcata dalla mia mappa
questo è un po cazzo sta suonando il
piano quando pensi di essere nella
stanza giusta premi m quindi allora qua
solo nella stanza john quella di mezzo
qui preme m
c'è la forza ragazzi scusatemi se ci
vuole un pochettino cos'è quadrate visse
vi ci vuole un pochettino per scoprire
gli enigmi ma sono abbastanza lento un
che ce l'ho fatta devo prendere a questo
è un altro tomtom è perfetto
ricordati credi soltanto la mappa io
credo sia la mappa che alla mamma quindi
se la mamma dice che non devo andare non
ci vado
quindi devo andare avanti di qua
perfetto non vi state divertendo dove
cazzo se infiniti permesso sono caduto
per sbaglio devo andare piuttosto dove
buongiorno ragazzi mi sa che qualcosa è
andato storto stamattina non so cosa ma
vabè ai persona autobus lavora che
questo non l'ho capita sinceramente
spero di trovare che cazzo che segue di
fraia sinceramente non ho capito dove
cazzo dover aggiungere come faccio a
raggiungere il punto c'è allora c'è
questa qualche quella triste e fin qua
ho capito e non ho capito se devo andare
di qua
oppure la a buongiorno tu sei quella per
imperfetto cioè siamo ragazzi ho trovato
le due facce ora devo trovare la plana
come canzone che ogni volta sbaglio di
un millimetro si a caso a caso non ci
posso credere ragazzi ho fatto a caso
completamente concreto legge
grazie mille liu in raga per festeggiare
stasera ci sbagliamo alla grande e
zucchero filato è che un giro per tutti
offrono zio da menez le centomila vorrà
che basta fare i [ __ ] voglio provare
ad andare avanti cos'è sta roba
c'è il bagno questo è il bagno dello
slider man è questo il bagno nello slang
airmen in gonnella con le trecce
fantastico raga non so dove siamo
non ha ancora capito tu che cazzo teri
di ragazzi dobbiamo andare avanti
get the next mezzi
map ha preso la mappa qui benissimo devo
andare a prenderla mappa per il prossimo
per il prossimo labirinto perfetto mai
regalano emozionantissimo quando ci
buttiamo giù da sti cosi mio dio mi
sembra di tornare bambino ragazzi che
cazzo guardi che farò solo aiutando
lui ti segue mentre tu lo guardi c'è in
poche parole mi guarda il culo ragazze
che questo ti che bello che tra l'altro
è fantastico io lo amo te che cazzo è
buongiorno gay che è un po magro ragazzi
che cazzo tweets corpo snello addominali
scolpiti sguardo accattivante mi sono
innamoratissimo
[Musica]
federico io lo so che mi vuoi perché mi
trovi sexy però devo devo scappare
perché mi stanno chiamando e chiamami
anche tu ragazzi questo tizio siamo
anche dolore allo stinco una volta dissi
chi mi ama mi segua ma non in questo
senso cioè c'è modo e modo ragazzi chi
cazzo è sto tizio ragazzi you want scape
next time cioè tu non scapperà i la
prossima volta
buongiorno facciamogli araki svolti a
prima ciglio ragazzi ho perso quattro
decimi dai take your map perfetto siamo
tornati nou dove siamo
assumiamo qui susciti questo questo era
il cesso ma io sono sono appena uscito
di qua non prendetemi per il culo ho
trovato una nuova mappa ho conosciuto il
nuovo amico che mi ama maledetti stronzo
siamo buongiorno sono fa vj ho bisogno
di indicazioni sto contorno funziona poi
tutto tranne te tranne te tranne te tra
anni sto [ __ ] regole o trovare
l'accordo distanza prima che un
pagliaccio mi stupì ok trovare quella
cazzo distanza da qualche parte deve
essere dove sono stipati non ci riguarda
io posso far questo tizio non trovo
nessun palloncino non ce ne sono
togliti dai [ __ ] vai a giocare con i
bambini non confavi gente si spaventa
siamo a ci sono quasi cup e capita
finiti via via di qui non ci credo
rapari fianco
[Musica]
sì sì sì
cazzo non ci credo sparato a caso ho
sparato completamente a casa una volta
che sono entrato qui dentro sé
ok ok dove cazzo si animò qui ma
affanculo e tre volte che cazzo è caduto
ragazzi soggiorno che sta diventando
sempre più strano fatemi uscire di qui
di cazzo certo il bagno che bel cesto
ragazzi devo uscire di qua perché mi sto
veramente preoccupandoci che chi cazzo
sono le montagne russe ragazzi mi
diverto troppo a vedere se cosa mi
sembra di tornare bambino forse non sono
mai cresciuto ma non importa ragazzi
dobbiamo andare avanti qua perché io
veramente so schierandolo starò
compresso mezz'ora a fare quel livello
di prima io vado avanti tipo scalato
anche ok ci sono ci sono bar [ __ ]
fermi devo guardare quel tizio devo
guardare perfetto regalo la ho inventato
anche le nuove scale mobili per noi ci
siamo ci dovremmo essere devo arrivare
dall'altra parte a guardare l'altro
tizio perché se non ce la facciano
aspettate che faccio un'acrobazia epica
ma devo guardare altro tizio perché se
non passo pensate che devo fare ancora
epica si perfetto ragazzi non credevo di
farcela ma ce l'ho fatta a c'è cosa che
ti amo dove vado anche stare attento a
non farmi accecare perfetto vai poi
tempismo tempismo tempismo sto cazzo un
hub affanculo sono caduto di brutto si
ok ok ok fermi fermi guardami stronzo
[Musica]
ma [ __ ] ok ok ok guardami guardami
guardami guardami to suzuka zucca zucca
ragazzi non so che sono innamorati di me
che vorrebbero guardarvi tutto il giorno
ma non possono nè loro nè il pagliaccio
[ __ ] ragazzi dove siamo qui ogni modo
dare un primo scommetto silos up e ci
avrei scommesso qualsiasi cosa allora
l'unico pagliaccio di merda spero di
farti indigestione ma mangiami vai così
ti faccio venire una cagarella ricco di
che stai al cesso per due settimane
abbiamo tutto buio ragazzi qualcuno
accende la luce
grandi ragazzi abbiamo vinto b web view
abbiamo vinto il gioco è stato
incredibile soprattutto perché sennò
sono veramente contento di esser
riuscita a rimorchiare un pagliaccio
ricordate i ragazzi gli occhi gli occhi
sono tutto se voi guardate fissa una
persona davanti agli occhi
questa persona si innamorerà di voi no
anche ragazzi se vi do è piaciuto come
al solito lasciate un commento mi piace
anche la pagina di facebook e come non i
video trovate la descrizione essere per
iscritti scriveteli ci vediamo un
prossimo video benghazi